i think if we had a trump versus biden  election held today i think trump wins  easily  um so the biggest gift that republicans  can really  give democrats right now  is to fight amongst themselves it's a  really sad commentary on the state of  the democratic party i'm not denying  that it is it is wild that the best  thing democrats have going for them  right now is that democrats that  republicans rather are fighting with  themselves trump republicans fighting  with the republicans that voted for  infrastructure trump republicans  fighting with mitch mcconnell because of  uh his actions in the senate uh it's  sadly and this is i mean listen  you know i'm not i'm not a democrat as  many of you know i don't care about the  democratic party  this is a really  embarrassing moment for the democratic  party given that the most optimistic  thing anybody can point to is  republicans seem to be damaging  themselves